In this lesson we are going to do an example of a refinement.
We will start with a very simple bank account application that allows deposits,
withdrawals, and queries about the current balance.
Here are some possible requirements.
The user can make a deposit of any positive number of dollars.
The user may make a withdrawal of any positive number of dollars so
long as at least that number of dollars is currently held in the account.
Their user may request the current value of the bank balance, which is defined
as the net value of all the deposits made minus the sum of all the withdrawals.
And initially the bank account is empty.